all right uh move
for so what's happening here is I'm
doing what we said I'm doing he's doing
what he's
doing okay but you're going to see as as
my arms go up come on as my arms go up
he enters okay that means as my arms go
up his chest is getting closer to
me so as his chest gets closer to me
that's I'm already going to move I'm not
going to stay here as in the static
version where I did move three and I
wave
there as his chest is moving towards me
I've already moved
okay if you pay attention scoot that way
Sean be behind me
here when you do a sh ten con you're
going to single pivot so you're going to
shift your weight onto the back foot
turn the back foot and you're going to
notice that I am moving to the left of
the center line by doing that okay if I
double pivot I stay on that Center Line
that line of attack much longer until I
get over what I want to do instead is
Turn Turn I'm on the other side of the
line of attack immediately so is Joe
come around Sean is here on the center
line and when I single point pivot I'm
on the other side of that line of
attack so you have to Tenon go back that
is how to do move
four but when to do move four is match
his chest so he goes oh I'm already
moving
okay and we'll do it slow at first again
my son's learning the form what I do is
I move is I reach out to touch his
weapon you have to do your part still
we're not going to go fast today go
back okay as I start to go I reach out
and touch the side of his weapon then I
rotate the cross so he's trying he has
upward energy I get around it to bring
his Center in and only enough range to
hit the cutting
portion
slower Reach Out boom
cut more get it out the
way
slower good
come
on this
SL
reach
wait reach
cut some
mistakes don't knock the thing out of
the
way
don't over
penetrate I don't need that his weapon
his Target's there I can be back here
and finish the
fight
other mistake don't over
twist you're literally going in
boom
deviation Readjustment
[Music]
flank how far do you flank how far do
you enter to hit the cutting portion on
the
wrist so Square so a good come on not
Twisted so we go slower strategy and
tactics I go out I'm matching his
chest match his
chest second strategy and tactics reach
out for him so as I go back boom Reach
Out establish adhesion then the atos
and the
cut chest reach out a and the
cut
no you can go slow but do it
fully there it
is
in your
shoulders switch
those so again he's been trained and if
I did that move full speed we'd break
his
arm you have to be able to receive the
bulk in energy in your Center just like
any any other chem technique okay right
now it's in his shoulders that's why I
keep hitting his hand so we go he goes
up
boom notice that when he does the atos I
receive the
atos in contrast to what he was doing
slower he does the atush and he just
takes it in his shoulder shoulders the
hand will get stuck and you'll cut the
hand a real person will do that that
works that gets his hand cut but UK is
not supposed to do that because UK is
supposed to survive the
form so I go one boom boom when he does
the
atos he does the atos that part I don't
put it in my
shoulders I take it in the center pull
and I move
again up
boom if you pay
attention boom
boom I'm going to stay on the bottom of
his stick if he doesn't keep swinging
past my target fights over
here so you have your move still okay as
supposed to take it it in your
shoulders and you're going to get stuck
pinned and hit on the hand okay let's
switch
rolls and see if you could be more
responsive
okay
no you're thinking that respon
responsiveness is
resistance in your
shoulders in your
shoulders same your shoulders
okay try it again okay as as I said
repeatedly your UK really determines
what you can and can't do okay um how
hard you can train because it's a matter
of safety so I'm not going to break him
okay um you have another UK who can keep
their Center in the weapon my son had my
older son has more experience he can do
that but he's learning okay my younger
son so you want to have drills to
develop the skill just like we did when
we working with Margaret on EO okay I'm
not going to shut her down I'm going to
give micro drills to help them get there
so here is a micro drill to help Not
freak out so what is happening is it
looks like it's nothing when I'm hitting
him but he has my energy and my presence
in that tip and it starts to generate
fear and fear makes the ike go away okay
and then he can't feel the adhesion he
won't feel it he he won't let that
happen so he takes it in his shoulders
as he tries to protect himself and
that's what keeps getting it hit so your
fear makes you do something that
actually makes your fear come true okay
so we're going to do a
drill he's going to keep in that
position I'm just standing here and I'll
do the adhesion and the swipe back and
he's just going to get used to
[Music]
it and this is the movement
but you you're on this side you're also
learning what were you doing okay so
you're not going like
this you're not going like this and then
moving in you're making a
circle
circle circle
cut circle cut
[Music]
good now the this one is important will
it trigger you or will you be able to
let go of it and keep going with the
actual
[Music]
present notice how I have to keep coming
towards you because you keep pulling out
you have to enter the
[Music]
fire don't let this one freak you better
don't pull
out okay try the drill
go all right so what you tend to do what
you even in all of your body AR is you
will pin his leg you'll pin his legs one
way or another the person will post okay
when he posts that's going to be the
young energy that I used to project him
it's no different in weapon fighting in
order for me to guarantee that he's not
going to dance out of this I have to pin
him but here you have a set where he has
to counter that move so in order to
counter that move I have to not be
pinable okay but he is trying to do a
pin so if we reverse that drill now my
energy was coming up in a
circle
okay he reaches out contact and goes
around the back of that Circle so he's
going to rotate the cross you see that
and that is what pulls me forward
Boom the mistake he was making is when
he felt the pull he lifted back on it
ever so slightly I don't know if you
could see it but I would feel it he's
technically pinned right now and that's
what makes his hand cutable it's holding
the Joe everything gets stuck in place
what we have to do is UK is get pulled
but move with
it I'm
not
consciously trying to get ahead of it
I'm actually letting myself get pulled
he goes
Co so my Center in the weapon he comes
around drops it it'll move me I'll do it
where I'm moving and not being pulled he
goes
different different I let him move
me
off my shoulders go
different even if it's down here go kid
in my shoulders he's going to cut the
hand and I'm pinned okay so we're just
doing the
[Music]
drill let's
go okay try it again
just
go this is conscious trying to mimic
what I'm
doing and then we didn't come
forward and then we consciously trying
to go
forward okay all right so it's not
you're not able to feel the technique do
the technique okay so we can't train at
safe speeds but I want to show you so in
your move you have upward energy in the
face right I'm not supposed to push down
be able to push down on your weapon nor
grab it out of your hands remember that
okay got it so you have upward energy
when you're going with Andre you don't
have any upward energy let it be loose
You' have that okay this another fear
response I don't want to give you the
energy it still pins you you see still
pins you you feel that weight on your
feet and I still going to cut your hands
okay so watch this you have upward
energy his weapon going to be here
upward
energy how come you
move think about it you you did move do
you feel that you have upward energy
here I am Bo it moved you forward how
can you
move think about it why I okay so I had
the iion right so I have to match Yang
energy got that okay
so now do the math where's the Y energy
in the upward energy do you get that and
when you have the upward energy then
right here got that so what you're doing
here is no
energy you got that and so when he goes
it just goes into your feet right away
into your feet pay attention you're not
aware of it feel it in your feet you
feel it it goes in your feet still it's
in your shoulders do you see that you
still are technically pinned he's still
going to come cut you caught that so
what you're do want to do instead in
order to survive the form is not get
pinned relax your body and let it
move okay got the idea so look how you
can allow the adhesion to happen here
you get it okay let's go
back and let's put this where it
goes that was conscious move
it okay last one was conscious movement
let's watch again okay look how ready
you are to do that do you got it do you
get it okay now we're going to ask the
question why can you do it here why can
you not do it
there yeah you do
it's you
no no why okay go back to that why do
you feel it more with the
hand because you're lifting up why do
you feel it less with the sword because
you're not lifting up why do you think
you're not lifting up this is another
way of faith of of yes there's no this
thing's not hitting
you that thing's hitting you that was
the same thing that was happening with
Tristan okay so the form as I said at
the beginning swords are going to teach
you to or Boke Joe the weapons are going
to teach you to reconcile fear at a
whole other level than the hand will
okay do you got it so as I do this
stuff interesting get
your uh
open I can't be freaking out okay so he
I have my intention my body's in it he
goes he hit it oh I don't give a f okay
my body mind has to be that I don't give
a crap about that pain I just do the
feeling and then you're going to be
conscious enough where you could
actually do stuff with it okay do stuff
with it got it but right now the fear is
in there you get pin if we go full speed
we just hit your hand so now we can't go
full speed now we don't know the weapon
we don't know what it's doing and we're
just hitting sticks do you got it so
let's try again from the top nice and
slow okay he goes up I feel reaches boom
clear go slower up reach for my weapon
don't go to
Jan reach for my weapon check boom cut
it
off reach for my weapon you're afraid of
my weapon reach and touch it that's the
first move up reach and touch it no
don't hit it yet reach and touch it
reach just reach and touch it clear
it reach and touch it check it boom cut
it back
here reaching you do you do go up there
do you get it do you understand that
another
switch I was going to do this move I was
going to do that mood but you changed
your mood so there's no point in going
here once your weapon is in range look
how I reach I never got to here go
back reach
boom
[Music]
reach
reach no
need I'm watching your
chest
reach all right let's go